we talk a lot about superheroes on this
channel so I thought it'd be fun to
check out from the channel top 5 best
top 10 real-life superpowers you won't
believe actually exist I love these kind
of videos we don't really cover them
that often but that'd be fun to mix it
up and go to a top 10 video that's not
about film let's do it
hello there YouTube we have all had that
dream of possessing superpowers whether
it's the ability to teleport go
invisible or have unbelievable strength
we all at one point in life and wish to
have extraordinary abilities more than
likely you're still wishing for a right
at this and what happens to it ii wonder
what life would be like with them Batman
spider-man Thor the x-men forget all of
them today we share the top 10 real
human superheroes in the world and
before we start that tap that subscribe
button and activate notifications with
the Bell I always use a million more Tom
Cruise's around Japan step in the
Wiltshire or sugar Oh sky are the
superhuman with the pack he has the most
incredible photo a grin remember world
and was able to recreate what he sees
into amazing pieces of art incredible
Devon was born in 1974 on April 24th in
London he unfortunately experienced
delays in learning which was caused by
autism a condition his parents found out
about later
interestingly enough the very first
words he ever spoke were pencil and
paper nobody would do later on in life
even before he could talk when he turned
five his parents into a school in West
London where his passion for drawing was
noticed he continued with his amazing
gift for the coming years until 2006
when he was officially honoured with the
title of a member of the Order of the
British Empire hers outstanding
contribution to art and Shakespeare
Blake's refer to him as the human camera
as he can
you're landscaped with his eyes and
later we create the example we do so
sexier but a sexy vanilla take you to
the Singapore panorama which he drew
with no reference at all injustice
deleted girl ring draaga hi have you
something embarrassing 148 exactly
number that's incredible your Aslam
adalah also known as magnetics the first
time I watched Miroslaw medulla I was
convinced whatever he was doing was
unwise it's hard to believe anyone can
stick metallic things on this thing
there's no gimmicks magnets to work we
would have them stay there for a minute
I suppose is capable of what most people
think is impossible he is the true
definition of a magnetic man he was born
and goes out what the philosophy in
Poland in the year 1958 as the youngest
of three children he was passionate
about politics and often shared his
opinions growing up okay
later on in life in the year 1992 each
of the world we developed an interest in
unlocking secrets of the mind and
psychokinesis from there he learned how
to use his mind to create a magnetic
field which could attract metallic
objects to his body he still says he's
not using his brain to anything near its
full potential I wonder what would
happen if he did that same guy right
over icing on our hands with magneto
number eight Oh Dean Colossus or
Marathon Man and every phones are
usually 26.2 miles long Dean Karnazes
runs up to seven marathons every day and
here's he does it every morning if an
order means places on earth and it's not
that he also had another marathon in the
North Pole which is the coldest place on
earth
so impressive that's ran 50 marathons in
50 US states in 50 days before
discovering his passion and stretching
out the possible limits incan magas was
a miserable van as his bike explains he
had enough money a great family a
beautiful home but he wasn't happy or
satisfied with any of those numbers 70
Leon I worry about these kind of kids I
don't either
you probably haven't ever seen a baby
with knives up Savia well Liam Chuck the
road with his skeletal structure and
muscle mass born in Michigan Liam
possess incredible abilities that are
very oh my god I can't even do that
yes I said five months he could easily
win an Iron Cross competition at that
point by the age of three his body
muscle ratio was a 40 percent he was
taking the doctors and after running
some tests they concluded he had a very
rare condition where his body compounds
restrict fat production and encourage
muscle creation Wow what again who is
number six Daniel when is the long term
negative effect of supply Daniel temed
was born in a blue Wednesday on January
31st 1979 he says it was a blue David
goes that's how his birth date appears
in his brain and so do all other numbers
numbers are his best friends he
describes numbers as shapes figures and
colors as a child he struggle with
epileptic seizures which got a scenario
when he turned 25 he was diagnosed with
Asperger's syndrome
despite all his illnesses he has
tremendous memory and can use his brain
to do mathematical calculations at a
superhuman level people describe him as
a project of odd due to his abilities
egg and gown 22,500 14 digits of 5 list
all the prime numbers between 1 and
90,000 and make 2 multiplications like
72 by 72 by 72 is so cool oh cool
number 5 slavi Zappa geek or current and
again I'm sorry if I butchered your name
their ever watched story wanted to be
like hair well guess what there is a
human being just like her although we
can't producer
well as the famous superhero Kenny
possesses superb abilities every year is
not just like people are treated for
electrocution most of them with severe
burns every year in the u.s. 60 people
died from electrocution for this reasons
Lovisa prajak is no ordinary human as he
can withstand voltage as high as 20,000
while the and little hurt by 50 volts
what had a very normal childhood was
born and raised in a middle-class home
and pause very comfy in Serbia and I'm
pretty sure I yeah at the age of 17 he
discovered his unique ability since then
he has set two Guinness records in 2003
and 1983 in addition to his remarkable
powers he can also store electricity in
his body he discovers it's when he said
an alcohol soaked cloth on fire with his
skin number I'll be like a real sewer or
monkey Ariel sorry Owen is a real-life
Spider Woman she can climb on a clip in
no time and make it appear as though she
is taking a comfortable stroll by the
park Tory was further Kavali Berlin
where she grew up with many animals and
had experiences the average kids dumped
she also had a pet monkey called Georgi
I spent four five years and she followed
him all over learning how to climb from
her friend by the age of 11 she became a
professional rock climber today she has
won every rock climbing competition she
has participated in and she has a way of
making it look so easy today Victoria
traveled the world advises history in
school tries forward and stay away from
drugs he advised them to get high from
games other than alcohol drugs no man
enough Elizabeth he's so much e or Roman
Esau is a samurai superhuman he has
sensory powers beyond the average human
being and he can use a sword in a way
that no one has ever been able to in the
past he is also a double Guinness world
record holder and in one of his amazing
shows he was able to cut through a BB
gun pellet that was moving at 200 meters
per hour
Wow
about him
this is on a whole different level of
sensory processing as he is not using
his vision it appears as though he is
using something so fluid something so
procedural and easy for him some say his
expertise as a result of his training
and dedication to sharpen his skills
DARPA de closely his ability to go
beyond the average field man
we can only classify him as a Superman
or Samurai Jack that's even cooler
number two Scott blinds Bert's
calculator Scott Landsberg is a human
calculator he was born in Herkimer New
York in 1964 they have a Kamini okay
later on this is more than just a
natural disco solar our incredible
mental calculator abilities at a young
age he was able to solve complex
mathematical calculations without having
to write it down or even use a
calculator when he be gaming you they
realize numbers and angle shapes
correlated which contributed to his
refusal of counting from one to ten then
study with lists numbers from zero to
nine
his ability to compute and grass
mathematics is so incredible such that
he can calculate and give mathematical
equation answers faster than a
calculator in addition to this he can
really exact date any previous day fell
on without even taking time to think
number D hello ages and days of the
Roman history float in his brain
we saved the best for last alright and I
save the best for last but first I have
a quick challenge
like it subscribe within the next five
seconds you'll get ten years of amazing
luck just give it a try
number one Stig Severinsen alias unknown
Stig Severinsen was born in 1973 in the
city of albergue and Denmark he has
known as Gill room his hometown this is
because of his ability to hold his
breath underwater longer than any human
being he has a PhD tell me about this
guy it's two records from Guinness on
four free diving world records drew
water rose impressive record is holding
his breath underwater for 22 yeah they
stayed underwater with no air supply for
more than 10 minutes
however Stig is no ordinary man he can
hold his breath for 22 minutes
underwater he is quite the Superman
transpeople has come close to
challenging his record and after testing
it was discovered that he can store red
blood cells in his spleen which ate him
and his impossible ability much like how
dolphins operate he says he appealed to
do this as he dedicated his whole life
to holding his breath and by doing this
constantly his body was able to adapt
discipline he was able to put his own
one punch man and that was our video for
today everybody I hope you enjoyed it if
you love that don't forget to hit the
like button and share with friends
family everybody subscribe to our
channel if you haven't please do
notification icons more updates on five
best ideas and a great day everybody
this is tops and oh thanks I'm putting
this together there's great bail love
the narration behind it - oh man let's
talk about that one I don't understand
why the government hasn't hired these
guys this is a real-life Avengers
waiting to happen this could be a real
superhero team-up man with the
photographic memory guy these are my
superhero names for them by the way
photo memory dude the rock-climb chick
ledge electric absorber I know that guy
would really do unless he needed to put
him in some really high stakes weird
scenario maybe he can go around static
shock people there's something or or fry
electronics like an EMP no there you go
Marathon Man a guy with that level of
cardio it would be funny if that guy
really has low stamina in the bedroom
though he's probably got a gigantic
heart though they got like two human
calculators on here I feel like that
would come in handy in some way I don't
know what kind of government job that
would really entail hey he's the kind of
you you want to have dinner would say
you don't need a whip out the calculator
for the tip am i right he's the guy you
can count on am i right now the
percentage am i right yeah now I'm very
jealous of all these people I'd kill for
even one of these I feel like the guy
with the photographic memory to me
that's like the sexiest gift because
you're able to draw someone and to do it
like in depth with no yeah it's like
it's portable you can do it anywhere it
doesn't involve like here give me some
pots and pans yeah I feel like if you're
chasing someone down and you have that
guy on the team and you need a
description of every sketch it up that's
just so cool
I love this story of the girl was a
Natori the the rock climber the world
she grew up in and the way the narration
made it sound made it seem like she had
a monkey friend that bond would ever
monkey master and then who bow in the to
string so cool just be able to climb
with your monkey that's every guy's
dream right there well that's beautiful
too because it shows what you can learn
from our animal friends yeah don't get
the point of what the magnetic guy was
doing I mean that's a cool ability I
don't understand it what was he trying
to achieve exactly yeah that's more of
like an oddity or like yeah like a
record or something something
interesting but I don't know what you
would have a practical useful or how he
would have figured that out too and
dance was he trying to create a magnetic
field and then it happened or did he
just stick his head to a pot and then
all of a sudden realize what he had to
hear something like that I mean you
could armor him up that way if he could
just cling metal in the body the
underwater breath guy I've heard about
just recently like a couple months ago
my buddy was telling me about him I
think there's like some documentary
about him now or he he does have videos
out there were teaches people methods on
how to develop this skill and to me
that's the most appealing one because a
lot of these people who are on here some
of them seems like you can train to
develop that ability like the rock
climber maybe even the samurai if you
really train hard dedicate your life to
it but the holding your breath ability
that would really come in handy because
I'm underwater way too often variety of
reasons every time I take a bath it is
such a stretch you're a kid too and you
play those like hold your breath
underwater for how long we're almost
trying to drown you and you could hold
your
breath underwater I'm thinking about all
the worst-case scenarios and how these
gifts would come in handy so somebody
could start trying to drown you and you
could wait for like ten minutes just so
they could tire themselves yeah that
would be amazing
how many kind of perfect plus you know
you can pretend to be dead
rude you would be definitely fifteen
minutes do you know in movies when the
car crashes they go off the highway and
they go in the water and then they they
they fire like a gun and and all the
bullets are spraying everywhere and it's
a cool underwater shot where the
boulders have been by underwater but
they're not hitting our main character
and they're like he must be dead and
then right when they walk away hero pops
up out of water yeah he wouldn't do that
he's saying there for 20 minutes just
well plus that would be great cos like
once you come out you could sneak you
could hold your breath if you were like
us a marksman or something you could
really steady your yeah like there's so
many extra applications beyond just
yelling surviving under water like that
I would say calling the samurai guy
Samurai Jack in this video I'd like to
believe that that guy would find that a
term of endearment because that is the
closest to a real-life anime samurai
I've ever heard of it yeah that is nuts
what he can do I mean he'd be coolest
when I have on your team he's a
real-life katana yeah right he can slice
up them just about food plus blessed do
we have to get tested now we plus you
never know what else he could slice
through that's not you know wood or you
know maybe good slice through concrete
or something like that that's true I
think with enough speed based off my
homeschooling I think you can do that
people do this with fruit but like to
the ad says have like three pieces of
bamboo or something like that and have
one consistent swipe like well they were
talking about the the BB gun bullet oh
yeah that was traveling like 200 miles
per hour and he was able to slice it I
left out of the video was they shot
about a hundred dollars a day it took a
really long
and you just give like swinging around I
thought one eventually had to get really
close to do it I'll never understand the
science behind any of this except the
buff child yeah I mean the buff child
ones always freaked me out we were young
there was a really popular figure called
little Hercules and that guy I actually
met one time you would never remember me
I'd remember him because once I met him
and he walked away people sometimes I
would see him in LA Fitness actually I
heard that kind of lifestyle was really
tough for him they have seen like
interviews apparently I had like a
really insane dad not really hope he
doesn't watch that kid he has an actual
genetic condition so that hearing that
kind of worries me of what possible
negative repercussions can occur from
such a thing and what is it food intake
have to be like cuz every once in a
while sometimes I'll be on Instagram and
I'll go down the parkour journey of just
watching a bunch of crazy stunts and
then somehow I'll land on the kids who
can do insane things like little Bruce
Lee is a really cool kid and then
there's one with a girl on her dad and
this girl's like you know practicing
punches on a tree and like these kids
scare me because the only when they grow
up yeah like what is their career gonna
be you know are they gonna become
professional fighters and just be
completely impossible to defeat or do
they grow a little resentful towards
this lifestyle who sacrificing
everything to become the mastery of
these things but that came with that
condition really impressive now I mean
whoever he goes to school I'm sure is
jealous of him cuz that's like the kind
of thing where you don't you're a kid
goes to school with a kid like that you
don't want to make fun and easily whoop
your ass like that's just the stupidest
thing woo you know it's like I could see
people like making fun of him behind his
back but you know if he heard it he
could just you know break your feet do
that thing where he breaks your facebook
just murdering at school this is where
these kind of videos take I don't talk
about the actual true beauties the human
form kind of power kind of how can we
monetize or utilize these people for our
own personal operatives right but the
human calculator would be a great
show-off ability at
party the Marathon Man one that seems
like so excessive that's it's a crazy
ability that he has I mean how much
glucosamine is that guy take how many
damage can his knees be at this point
over a hundred miles so many days that's
gotta yeah like be doing a number on all
of his joints and ligaments and
everything like that like I wonder if he
maybe has some special condition with
that well it seems like the psychology
of the way this video these broke him
down was that there is a sense of
escapism and he's chasing like if you
guys heard that term runner's high he's
taking it to a whole new extreme because
gunplay is there saying he did he had
the money and the family but that didn't
make him happy so he's getting like the
scientific dopamine endorphins effects
of just all this excessive running to
achieve it which is crazy and yeah I'd
love that ability how do you have the
time for things does he see his family
does he still have that family or did he
give up all that stuff to only ever run
because it seems lady he ran away from
home and responsibility which one of
these superpowers would you most like to
have and what would you use it for which
one would you most want to fight
subscribe to top 5 best subscriber the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified whenever we got a
video up last but not least David ganda
Nader David Gandy how you doing buddy
there's anyone at our patreon who's a
real-life superhero it's this gentleman
the guy is massively talented has a wide
array of so many artistic skills the
more I get to know him more traitor than
I ever realized
wicked fingers on the guitar he has a
huge heart a huge heart it's it's kind
of dangerous it's gonna grow out of his
his chest one day and consume the planet
is a hundred and twenty years old
and he's still doing martial arts buff
since he was a child it's crazy how
skilled David is he's also also the most
important quality of all superheroes
he's a protector and I mean that
genuinely he looks after those that he
loves he will go to
for anyone he'll take a bat to anyone
who threatens the ones he loves I don't
know about that part seen it I know I
don't know anyone else like him to the
degree of how much sacrifice he has made
to tend look after those that he cares
about is a beautiful human being
he's turning 140 next year and that's
the most super thing of all it's crazy
oldest man alive and David Gandy but
looks 45 yeah it's pretty impressive
he's od'd at least 10 times in the last
year and trying to die he Han wakes
himself up taking many bullets sliced a
few of them in half with his teeth
during a mountain climb I cannot believe
how impressive this guy is these are all
sincere thoughts about you David and
they're all available in the Guinness
Book of World Records